the jurogan experience even though we
just got through a [ __ ] horrible year
that year exposed a lot of weird [ __ ]
about our civilization
it's it exposed a lot of weird [ __ ]
about a bunch of really
freaked out people that are just
paranoid and
schizophrenic and how many people that
are
just fragile there's so many fragile
people in our culture
i was blown away by the politics of it
i'm a politician so this is what i
analyzed and i was blown away
that the the conversation about how to
deal with the last year
became or it the division
the division fell upon partisan lines
right about whether to lock down or not
to lock down about
whether people liked masks or didn't
like masks
and at first that seems really odd and
so i spent a lot of time
analyzing this because it shouldn't be
that way it should
it should be mixed you would you would
think about just because what you're
really talking about is somebody's risk
assessment
and you know how they perceive risk and
how they want to deal with that and how
they think everybody else should deal
with that
and um it's strange i think there's a
lot of factors involved i do think that
there was some political opportunism
i think that if trump says something
people reactively say the opposite
that's a problem right
and then that's definitely part of it
however um after trump lost the election
he that didn't stop that that movement
again you know for pro lockdown movement
never stopped so it didn't it was not
clear to me then that that was the only
reason but it's but it is
see the problem is once people get
committed to an ideology or committed to
a narrative
yeah just because trump lost and now
biden's in power
it's not like everybody just abandons
this narrative and
creates a new reality based on objective
truth but they'll never even do a
do a an after action report on it so the
point where it's
to where it's ridiculous and
and so so i i put another i put another
a few factors in there i i think some of
it is the fact that
uh democrats tend to congregate in urban
areas and it might be
you know the virus is more in your face
in an urban area than in a rural area
there might be some explanation there
for sure right but it really boils down
to and there's there's
studies on this where our our brains
light up differently uh when assessing
risk
now it doesn't mean that the behavioral
outcomes of these studies are changed
basically they would they would take
liberals and conservatives and they
would give them a bet it
would bounce to a betting game and see
how they react differently now that now
the actual behavioral outcomes what they
choose
wasn't didn't change all that much but
when they're doing the mri scans
they see that their brains light up
differently so that's interesting so we
clearly assess risk differently somehow
so i'd looked at data on the kind of
jobs that we choose
and it turns out and this is intuitive
you would guess this
that the vast majority of conservat or
vast majority of dangerous jobs are
are mostly populated by conservatives
lumbered jacking
hard labor uh military law enforcement
so there's
it's obvious that we're choosing to
engage in risk differently
just overall in the aggregate and so
i think that gets at why we think
differently about this i think we're
truly wired differently
and out on top of that the the natural
disposition of a liberal to believe in
some sort of collective action
whereas the natural disposition of a
conservative is to believe
that government can only do so much
right there there's life
out there and it's sometimes it's
dangerous and it's up to you as an
individual
to generally assess that and that's also
the most efficient way to do things
in order to get the best outcomes in the
aggregate so these are two dispositions
that are always
present and they manifest in policy
outcomes all the time
and in this case it's pretty obvious how
they manifested into the
into the way we dealt with coronavirus
um
and i think that kind of explains it
because you know and think about this
way too
when a more left-leaning public health
official talks about it
they always give you the worst case
scenario well it's possible that if
you're 15 you could die
well yeah it's possible but it's also
far more unlikely than even if you got
the flu
they don't they say they leave out that
part they leave out the context they
leave out the probabilities this is why
i've been so frustrated with our public
health officials
give us the whole truth right don't just
give us the most dangerous truth don't
don't
tell us the tail end of the probability
uh scale like that's that's not
useful information to us very it's been
very frustrating to watch how we've
dealt with this over the last year
around the world not just in america
frankly we've had it better than a lot
of countries
i think people tend to try to find a
group
that they can attach themselves to and
chris rock has a great bit about this
you know what you can find uh mick
maynard who is uh one of the uh
matchmakers for the ufc
posted this on his instagram um go to
uh mick you got it yeah okay
so mick maynard posted this from the
great and powerful chris rock
and this is uh we can watch this because
it's on his instagram and if
chris will holler at me if it's it's an
issue but i [ __ ] love chris rock and
this is one of the
the best points it might not be one of
his best bits
but it's one of his best points ever
because he's so it's so accurate
because he's talking about we all got a
gang mentality
republicans are [ __ ] idiots and
democrats are [ __ ] idiots
and conservatives are idiots and
liberals are idiots
and anyone that makes up their mind
before they hear the issue
is a [ __ ] fool okay
everybody now that hold up everybody's
so busy wanting to be
down with a gang i'm a conservative i'm
liberal i'm concerned it's [ __ ]
be a [ __ ] person listen
let it swirl around your head then
form your opinion no normal decent
person
is one thing okay i got some [ __ ] i'm
concerned
about i got some [ __ ] i'm liberal about
crime i'm conservative prostitution
i'm liberal
it goes on but that's where the clip
ends but that's so
accurate is that what a lot of people
are afraid of is being alone they're
afraid of being attacked and one of the
things about
today's culture particularly with social
media
is that it's an attack culture it's a
bully culture and a lot of these people
that are doing the attacking
and they're doing the bullying they've
been bullied in the real world so they
want
paybacks they're trying to bully people
online and that's what you see
there's a lot of like low status males
a lot of like really weak people who
have never
really overcome physical adversity or
they're not successful but they found a
way online to gather up a group of
people that
resonate with some of their opinions and
they can attack people
and they do it all day long you know
this is i find that to be the most
it's fascinating the most probable if
somebody's uh saying something
extremely crude and awful to me online
it's probably a
a younger man it doesn't necessarily
sometimes it's older men who have
failed their life and they've just
they've decided that this is their stand
this is their line the sand they're
going to draw
with it now they're going to be
anti-racist or they're going to be
you know anti-homophobic or
anti-transphobic or whatever it is and
they're going to attack all these people
whether or not there's so many different
ideological pathways that you could
choose that you could get a group of
people that agree with you
and then you fight against anyone that
opposes these ideas and you do it in a
really
aggressive and nasty way which is
something that we should
push back against period like ideas
should be something that you should be
able to
discuss and and debate
and analyze you should be able to sit
down and go why do you believe in the
simulation theory you know and
we shouldn't be like well you're a
[ __ ] idiot joe rogan that's why you
agree
it should be like yeah i'm a [ __ ]
idiot yeah but that's not why i agree
with this that's not why i look at this
i look at this because i'm curious and i
i see all the various components
you know i think there's a lot of
there's there's a lot of
truth on both sides but the problem is
when you ignore the truth on a side that
doesn't fit with your ideology
then you're not interested in truth
you're interested in what chris rock is
talking about you're interested in
supporting your gang
so yeah and that's your gang or team i
always say that you're either wearing a
blue jersey or a red jersey and then you
act accordingly
and you repeat these sort of mantras
that you think you're supposed to repeat
in order to
to gain favor within that group make
them make sure they know you're part of
the loyalists
there and if and if you don't say the
things then then then that group gets
distrustful of you we but this is a
problem we have on the right right so i
think the left is power hungry i think
the right is paranoid
and we tend to look for for betrayers in
our in our midst right we look
who's paranoid who's power hungry which
is right the right is more apparent can
you switch it back and forth though
left is powerful sure times two look
look everybody's on a spectrum
right so and i should say that in the
beginning right i'm talking i'm
analyzing in the aggregate the
coronavirus
why why why people fell on partisan
lines on that but
i mean look i recognize that not all
liberals are risk averse to
this extraordinary degree i recognize
that we're all on a spectrum
um and from from the left to the right
but but in the in the aggregate this is
sort of what we see
and then in politics as you're talking
about we put on these jerseys
and so i'm just talking in generalities
right okay of course the left can be
ultra paranoid um and of course the
right in in its extreme form can
can exhibit more power-hungry tendencies
but it but it tends not to be and if you
and if we look at the
policies actually being implemented that
tends not to be the case
but what i see on my side because i'm
always dealing with my side
we tend to be looking instead of instead
of thinking how to
persuad this is the problem i have and
i'm trying to change
the that i have i mean that i think we
have
i we talk about fighting all the time
and i say look we have to define
fighting as persuasion
persuasion is is the name of the game in
politics look i can
i can go charge a hill as a seal
and that's fighting right i mean it
looks cool but i'm gonna die
okay what i really should do is
communicate
maneuver and and kill the enemy that
enemy that way in politics that the
fight must be persuasion
and and too often we we get more
concerned with you know
saying the things saying the slogan
saying the things that make us feel good
that make us
that that that help us recognize one
another as part of the same
team wearing the same jersey i think
that's what he's getting at
if somebody veers from that well they're
a traitor
uh they're not one of you and then
they're automatically wrong and
instead of saying uh i knew you're going
to say that let me
let me tell you why it's wrong let me
explain it to you let's have a debate
about it we get really mad
and we go online and we call names
because we haven't actually done the
background work
to at least understand why we think what
we think and when you understand why you
think what you think that's how you can
persuade people
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience